Stephen Gostkowski is extended tenure
with the New England Patriots has come
to and and he had been there for 12
seasons he was the kicker that they
acquired in the draft after Adam
Vinatieri left for the Indianapolis
Colts they stuck with Gostkowski through
some some not great performances
remember the missed extra point in the
AFC Championship game in 2015 and I know
you'd have to play out the rest of the
game from that point forward but you
know that was the difference between
possibly going back to the Super Bowl
again and not going there and all kind
of strange it happened this week if you
cut him last week he's out there in free
agency and can end up getting signed not
that teams are clamoring for kickers
right out of the gates in free agency
but kind of strange the Patriots in my
view strange that they kept them around
more than a week beyond the the opening
of the free agent market yeah I mean
you're right you would think that a guy
that's done is good for the New England
Patriots as Gostkowski has done that
they would have maybe got him out the
door and let them either shop himself
free agency wise but I think the point
you made is right Mike I mean first off
nobody's you know clamoring for the
kicker position yet you know these will
be one of those things as we get further
in the long and free agency you'll start
to look at kickers more other options
and you know the big thing too is I
don't think New England was like
deliberately doing this to screw over at
Gostkowski you know I think they're a
team that was kind of trying to figure
out they had a lot of things to figure
out here as of late you know they had to
make some moves they signed a few
players lost a few players of course
we're waiting for Tom Brady so I think
all that was part of this formula that
led to Gostkowski finally seeding him
get it released by doing of a mint
I mean hey we talked about Vinatieri and
all the greatness he brought to the
Patriots Gostkowski okay it might not be
been a terry level but it's pretty damn
special as far as big kicks big moments
consistency I mean he really did it off
of that organization it was one of the
better kickers in football in the last
few years and you never know how the
Domino's are gonna fall with the
Patriots they could bring him back at
some point for all anyone knows maybe
they just didn't want to pay whatever he
was due to make on the second year of
the contract he signed a year ago ended
bonne danger preserved last season and
they had a revolving door at the kicker
position not nearly as big of a concern
for the Patriots as in the past because
they've got far bigger fish to fry in
New England with Tom Brady gone but
still a concern because it's a critical
position if you're gonna be in close
games you need to have a kicker who can
make kicks Stefon Diggs as we said last
week the Patriots were in on the
conversations for digs that ultimately
resulted in Diggs being traded from the
Vikings to the Buffalo Bills Albert
Brewer of si.com pointed out yesterday
that it was the tweet that that Stefon
Diggs posted last week and remember we
talked about both of them and they were
kind of happening in real time as we
were taping videos last Monday Digg
saying time for a new beginning and then
somebody called him out that he was just
being dramatic and he said no
something's going to happen and he kind
of spoke it into existence the trade
came together that night between the
bills and the Vikings along the way the
Patriots did have some conversations
with the Vikings but ultimately the
bills were the ones who ended up
snagging Stefon Diggs and you know it
all started with that tweet Chris well
it's amazing you know first off I'm not
surprised to hear the Patriots are in
that conversation Mike I think you've
heard me say a few times here I think I
sent it a few times last week I know
they love Stefon Diggs he's a perfect
fit for their system that's why Buffalo
like them Brian Dave all came from New
England he knew that but Diggs I mean
Mike I've been around him a few times I
know you have - he is really really
smart I would not be shocked that he
pulled something like this off he
understands the league has a great feel
for it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports